against the backdrop of a colorado
conservation center the romance of the
century is about to unfold
in 2022 researchers will attempt to
breed elizabeth anne
the world's first cloned black-footed
ferret with a captive male if successful
their offspring will infuse the
critically endangered species with a
splash of genetic diversity
cloning for the sake of conservation
isn't unique to black-footed ferrets
another endangered species clone is a
chevolski's horse named kurt but kurt
isn't yet ready for breeding
and other earlier clones of bantang and
gower were essentially proofs of concept
they were never bred limiting their
genetic relevance a lack of genetic
diversity is a big problem in
re-establishing a species population if
captive animals are too closely related
they're at risk of inbreeding that can
hobble their reproductive fitness
stymieing family trees
cloning can help bypass this problem
bringing into play a more genetically
distant relative to breed with animals
already in captivity
in elizabeth ann's case scientists took
cells grown from a skin sample of a long
deceased black-footed ferret preserved
in test tubes at the san diego frozen
zoo to craft an embryo then transferred
it to a domestic ferret that brought the
embryo to term
this process somatic cell nuclear
transfer has been used for decades to
duplicate livestock and pets
cloning for conservation meanwhile has
been on the back burner for a few
reasons breeding practices are less
developed for species in need of
conservation and there's less commercial
interest in maintaining endangered
animals
also cloning for conservation has a
tricky endgame
to keep a species as genetically pure as
possible
biologists prefer the clones family tree
contain only the genes of the endangered
species
animals cloned by somatic cell nuclear
transfer still carry their domestic
mother's mitochondrial dna
this means the offspring of a cloned
animal such as elizabeth ann stand to
bring domestic genes into the endangered
population
but because mitochondrial dna is
inherited from an animal's mother
these domestic genes can be ferreted out
by breeding the male offspring of clones
with captive females
if successful the process could make an
endangered population more resilient and
eventually lead to self-sustained growth
just over a month removed from her first
birthday elizabeth anne remains a marvel
in her own right
if she finds her captive male suitor to
be just as marvelous their
once-in-a-lifetime romance could propel
their species for lifetimes to come
[Music]